une plainte pour crimes de guerre
torturé financement de terrorisme a été
déposée à paris contre mohamed bin zayed
et mohamed ben berden salman par joseph
breham avocat français spécialiste du
droit pénal international pour lui aucun
doute la france est bien impliqué dans
la guerre au yémen
on a trouvé des armes vendues non pas
l'arabie saoudite mot émirats unis mais
des armes américaines vendues aux
émirats arabes unis est entre les mains
d'al-qaïda la france elle vance mais
surtout des armes d'assez aux
technologies et ces armes là je n'ai pas
trouvé sur place la preuve de
l'utilisation de ces armes sur des
hommes de crimes de guerre aujourd'hui
au yémen ce qui crée le plus de morts
c'est le blocus le blocus de l'aide
humanitaire le blocus du pétrole le
blocus de la nourriture qui ne peut pas
rire et ce blocus il a été mis en place
il a été ordonné par la coalition or ce
blocus il est mis en oeuvre par des
bateaux qui sont des bateaux français
qui ont été vendus par la france et qui
sont toujours ceux qui juridiquement
parlant ont fait une haie qui sont
toujours maintenus en condition
opérationnelle par la france donc oui la
france est directement impliquées dans
un gang